the standard cosmological model was that
it emerged from a big bang and that the
Universe was expanding but that at some
point it would contract back on itself
and this was Hawking's idea anyways and
then collapsed back down into another
Singularity it's my understanding that
over the last few decades evidence has
accrued in controvertible manner that
the rate of expansion is actually
increasing rather than decreasing and I
believe that's the great mystery that's
propelled scientists who posit the
existence of such phenomena as dark
energy first of all explain why that's
surprising that the rate of increase or
the rate of expansion is increasing and
then when you explain how that view has
changed over time and where we're at now
so I got to hear Stephen Hawking speak
at the Royal Astronomical Society
meeting in London in 1995. he couldn't
speak for a very long time so he wasn't
able to actually speak in real time but
he could move his fingers and he could
move his eyes and he could type on this
very special keyboard which the
ex-husband of his current nurse at the
time had invented that's a whole other
story I can recommend a book by my
friend Charles seif called Hawking
Hawking he could answer one question and
it would take him about 10 minutes to
answer a question someone asked him in
the audience Professor Hawking you're
rumored to be the most brilliant man
alive and yet you've written this book
that almost no one besides you know a
younger Jordan Peterson perhaps had red
cover to cover why did you write this
book and he answered in his computerized
synthetic voice because my daughter
needed to pay for college interesting
that this great man this great intellect
you know trapped in this body that had
you know been robbed of all of it
physical kind of maneuvering and so
forth so facile with his mind it was
really an incredible thing to see when
Hawking wrote that book it is true the
expectation was that the Universe would
eventually collapse on itself would
eventually undergo what's called a big
crunch which is essentially the the
opposite of the Big Bang we would
observe if we were living billions of
years hence the story went that we would
see not galaxies being red-shifted but
galaxies being blue shifted because
we're all going to combine and
eventually into a collapse of an
enormous if you like gravitational time
bomb
foreign